for every forgettable blockbuster that
has come and gone there's been a steady
stream of stellar under-the-radar action
flicks what they lack in terms of scale
and big-budget effects they make up for
with their share of bone shattering
brawls white-knuckle chases and bloody
bombast a few years back writer director
Ted Gaugin made a name for himself among
the genre set with the atmospheric
haunted house film we are still here
though the films no budget production
limited what Gaugin could ultimately
accomplish there was enough style on
display to get excited about what the
filmmaker would do next
surprisingly instead of horror Gaugin
jumps to gory action in mohawk Mohawk
unfolds in the last days of the war of
1812 and finds a young Mohawk woman and
her lover's squaring off against a
violent band of American soldiers Mohawk
might flag a bit in dialogue heavy
scenes but when Gaugin leaves words out
of the mix this under scene actioner has
as much energy and vision as any
blockbuster if you've got an Amazon
Prime subscription then you're probably
aware of the streaming services new
action series Hanna what you might not
be aware of is that the show is based on
a 2011 film of the same name that film
ended up doing moderately well at the
global box office but it feels like it's
been all but forgotten by audiences in
the years since like the series the film
version of Hanna follows a teenage girl
who has a penchant for putting down bad
guys with a graceful brutality all the
while she's hunted by a secretive
intelligence operative a mirthfully
menacing cate blanchett hannah is a taut
boldly stylized pseudo detective action
fantasy that delivers a weighted payload
in terms of both pulse-pounding
set-pieces and character driven drama
it's high time this action-packed gem
got rediscovered I just missed your
heart
for many American moviegoers exposure to
the work of Japanese extreme auteur
Takashi Miike begins and ends with his
dark 1999 masterwork audition
understandable as it may be you're doing
yourself a disservice by ignoring his
other films among meuk a sprawling
output you'll find the work of a
visionary filmmaker with a flair for
genre a penchant for gore and plenty of
eye popping action you get plenty of all
that in me case 2010 samurai stunner 13
assassins set in the waning days of
feudal Japan the film setup promises a
harrowing showdown between the title
assassins and the Shogun's ruthless
brother whose upcoming promotion
threatens to bring chaos to the
otherwise peaceful Japanese landscape
Mika takes his time getting to that
showdown meticulously building toward
the fateful finale with a screenplay
that allows audiences to get good and
comfy with the anti heroes and villains
of the piece when meet Kay finally blows
the lid off 13 assassins he does so with
a bloody brutal savagery all but unseen
in American cinema wheelman follows a
freshly paroled getaway driver played by
Frank Grillo who finds himself
double-crossed and on the run fittingly
for a movie following a character played
by longtime character actor Grillo the
film is very much the sort of pulpy
crime flick that plays to his strengths
writer director Jeremy rush gives his
star ample room to talk tough act up and
drive hard rush amplifies the film's
inherent machismo by keeping his camera
confined almost entirely within a single
car it's a bold stylish move that pays
off in spades giving a fresh perspective
to the sort of car crashing fist
fighting and machine gunning we've seen
a million times over Geneva
don't want to talk chitchat I don't
chitchat about the job one day the world
at large will catch up to the genius of
writer director Joe Cornish when it does
the likely look back on 2011 s attacked
the block and wonder how it ever became
a box-office bomb hornish's film
delivers the action-packed stoner comedy
alien invasion horror flick the world
never knew it needed
sadly the world still seems oblivious to
the sharply written exquisitely executed
genre mashup despite the jaw-dropping
action scenes and killer creature design
not to mention what should have been
star making turns from future Doctor Who
star Jodie Whittaker and later Star Wars
star John boyega do yourself a favor and
check out this hidden gem though the
bloodshed has finally stopped the
simmering tensions that drove Irish
Catholics and Protestants headlong into
the carnage of the troubles remains a
part of life in Northern Ireland in
Belfast circa 1971 the setting of 71 the
divisive fires that drove the madness
still burned with the raging heat of
bombed out cars and gunpowder 71 opens
with a kindly new recruit joining a
British military regiment in the
war-torn streets of Belfast the film
pivots sharply when an angry mob ends up
separating the man from his retreating
regiment leaving him lost alone and
injured in a situation where he's
perceived as an enemy to one and all
from there the film plunges viewers into
a breathless night long race for
survival through an unforgiving
landscape where vengeance is righteous
no matter the cost
71 is that rarest of the action films
that dares to examine both the human
cost of the bloody conflict and a cycle
of hate that fuelled it in case you
missed out on haywire in theatres the
film follows a tough-as-nails black ops
agent called Mallory who finds herself
hunted by international mercenaries
after being double-crossed in a
clandestine mission with plenty of grit
brawn and brains
Mallory quickly turns the tides on her
betrayers setting up a hunted becomes
the hunter revenge tale for the ages
though haywire marked director Steven
Soderbergh first full
action flick you'd never be able to tell
by how effortlessly he executes the
film's intricate set pieces style and
whimsy most action movies never even
aspire to that Soderbergh cast legit mmm
a star gina carano in the lead role only
serves to legitimize each vicious
escalation even as the film
unapologetically begins to earn its
title it all makes haywire and overlooks
diamond among Soderbergh impeccable
filmography if you'd have told us a few
years back that we'd be listing a
certified fresh' Tom Cruise fronted
sci-fi epic among our underrated action
movies picks we probably would have told
you you were completely insane yet here
we are half a decade after its release
still wondering how so many people slept
on this intelligent action-packed Bangor
edge of tomorrow which follows a soldier
continuously killed during a deadly
alien assault only to be dropped right
back into the action is worth
remembering this Groundhog Day esque
action film is a classic one that
matches epic human drama against an
equally epic scope it's also a film with
an insanely cool sci-fi concept with
mind-boggling special effects and set
pieces that make repeat viewings
endlessly rewarding if you haven't seen
it go watch it if you have seen it see
it again I would go with the a sense of
manifest destiny rags-to-riches rapid
rise through the ranks born to deliver
us and the people they love that sort of
thing few genres are is well primed to
build big-time action into a narrative
as science-fiction while Hollywood has
given us its share of super-sized sci-fi
bombast over the years audiences have
proven themselves equally open to
experiencing more concept driven
science-fiction fare while Leigh
Whannell scamp tinged techno-thriller
upgrade sits firmly in the latter
category this unpredictable tale wholly
embraces its big-budget ambition it's
the sort of savvy small-scale
science-fiction that deserved a much
broader audience if you're among those
who missed upgrade in theaters it
follows a technophobic every man who
blazes a path of bloody vengeance after
a mugging leaves him paralyzed and his
wife dead he's aided in that endeavor by
stem a computer chip that allows him to
walk as well as dole out plenty of
violence on his attackers from start to
finish one Nell spins a wholly
original action-packed sci-fi tale from
clear influences all while having way
more fun with its hottie yet silly
concept than most action movies would
dare you now have full control again
grey let's take a moment to talk about
Jeremy Sonya's harrowing survival drama
green room a film that couldn't find its
audience even with a glowing review from
Quentin Tarantino oddly that may simply
be the result of one too many people
pegging sanyas Punk tinged chiller as a
horror film while the story itself is
endlessly horrific Green Room might have
found its audience if viewers had been
expecting a first-rate action flick
instead that's not to say there aren't
ghouls aplenty in green room there are
they just happen to be of the very human
neo-nazi persuasion their prey a
down-on-their-luck hardcore band are
equally human when they inadvertently
witness a murder while on tour the
band's instinct is to hightail it out of
town their Nazi counterparts have other
plans which gets even worse when they're
sneering leader shows up and essentially
condemns the band to death from that
moment on greenroom breathlessly propels
itself forward with the filth and the
fury of a punk-rock Thrasher indulging
in unflinchingly tents showdowns and
grueling acts of violence every step of
the way Sonnier delivers an insightful
surprisingly timely action thriller
that'll leave your brain racing and your
heart pumping overtime in case you
hadn't noticed Netflix has been churning
out movies at a feverish rate over the
past several years of course with their
under-the-radar release strategy and
general lack of proper promotion it's
entirely likely you've missed out on
more of those releases than you thought
we'd lay even odds that the blistering
brutal gangster drama the night comes
for us is among the films you missed if
that's the case it's an oversight that
action fans will want to rectify
immediately because this blood-soaked
crime drama packs a punch you won't be
able to shake at the center of that saga
is a former triad enforcer named Ito who
while slaughtering an entire village for
his bosses stays the execution of a
young girl in doing so he sets off a
bloody chain of events that puts the
Triad on their trail matters get
insanely violent from that moment on
with a ceaseless
wave of triad henchmen armed with cool
names cool weapons and cooler than cool
attitudes taking on eco and a few loyal
members of his old crew bones are broken
limbs are severed bodies are set a flame
or blown to bits through all the
grueling meticulously orchestrated
action the film also manages to capture
a deeply human story of redemption for
action fans of a certain age the late
80s remain a fertile time period for a
particular sort of absurdly predictable
and way over-the-top action flick
there's no doubt that genre maven Adam
Wingard is one of those fans and a
stylized horror tinge thriller the guest
is all the proof you'll ever need for
the uninitiated being predictable and
over-the-top aren't really hindrances to
this sort of film in fact the mixture of
seriousness and absurdity is all part of
the fun wyngarde and screenwriters Simon
Barrett have about as much fun with that
approach in the guests as a filmmakers
have ever had leading the charge for the
film's giddily over-the-top vibe is Dan
Stevens who delivers a fascinatingly
unhinged performance as a mysterious
soldier who befriends an unsuspecting
family
he's ostensibly there to pay respects to
their son who supposedly died in combat
while serving alongside Stevens
character without spoiling any of the
dizzying madness we'll just say that the
man isn't who he claims to be as bodies
start piling up around town the guest
twists and turns from eerily stolen
identity drama into a surreal neo-noir
horror show rife with all the genre
affectations one could ever hope for you
want the elite well I'll take them all
although all the angles know everything
all your guns check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you